hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast translating airway gene
expression into a biomarker for lung
cancer and COPD I'm Bob word of lab Ruth
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green QA button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green suit a button on
the lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Optimus tira
dr. spira is a professor of medicine
pathology and bioinformatics and
alexander graham bell professor in
healthcare entrepreneurship at boston
university he is found in chief of the
division of computational bio medicine
in the department of medicine at Boston
University and director of the
translational bio informatics program at
Boston University's clinical and
translational Science Institute as
inactive clinician scientist is also an
attending physician in the medical
intensive care unit at Boston Medical
Center please join me in welcoming dr.
spira I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you I appreciate that
for again I appreciate the opportunity
to present this very unique setting I'll
be spending the next 40 minutes or so
telling you about some of our work on
developing gene expression based
biomarkers to impact care of patients
with lung cancer and chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD before I do
that though let me get my disclosures
out of the way I'm a founder and
consultant to a molecular diagnostic
company called Allegro Diagnostics that
company was required
six months ago now by a publicly traded
company in california called variscite
variscite has now launched a commercial
version of one of our gene expression
biomarkers for lung cancer detection
that i'll be telling you about today on
the next slide is an outline of the
three areas i hope to toddler over the
next 40 minutes i'm going to tell you
how gene expression signatures in airway
epithelial cells can serve as clinically
relevant biomarkers to impact to smoking
related lung diseases the first part of
the talk is going to focus on early
detection of lung cancer and how
bronchial airway gene expression can
impact that aspect of disease i will say
that's a very mature project that
molecular bio marker as i mentioned is
already moved into the clinic so it's a
bench to bedside success story the
second bullet point is is moving from
lung cancer to another smoking-related
lung disease called COPD and the idea
here is using gene expression in the
same airway epithelial cells to help
guide therapeutic strategies in that
disease and i'll tell you a little bit
more about that in a moment I last not
least the third area that I wanted to
cover is an emerging area within our
group which is to use arrow aging
expression as a measure of a
physiological response to a variety of
inhaled toxic exposures in our
environment and in particular I'll show
you one example of electronic cigarette
smoke but let me begin with the basic
hypothesis that underlies all the work
i'll be showing you today the so-called
field of injury and this really is the
basis for all of the biomarkers that
will be presented the concept is as
follows in individuals who smoke even
though diseases that prolong that
developed like lung cancer and emphysema
or copd tend to develop deep within the
lung parenchyma all of the epithelial
cells that line that respiratory tract
from your mouth and nose all the way
down to your large airway epithelium all
of those cells are exposed to all the
toxins in cigarette smoke and they have
genomic alterations as a result so the
little player here
so the sort so the idea here is that
these cells have a certain genomic
response to the exposure and that how
one smoker respond to the exposure and
how it varies between smokers associates
with risk for developing tobacco-related
lung disease most specifically lung
cancer but as I hope to show you today
also COPD so if that hypothesis were
true then one could imagine developing a
relatively simple tool to identify
smokers at risk for having or developing
lung cancer simply by collecting cells
that line the upper airway and again
we'll show you in a moment how we do
that and measuring the complete set of
gene activity in these cells and
deciding is that a smoker on their way
to cancer or not so based on that
relatively simple hypothesis our group
now has spent the last I'd say greater
the last 10 years working on developing
an early detection strategy for lung
cancer and the reason that's important
to shown on this slide so many of you
may know this already but one cancer is
the number one cause of cancer deaths in
the world by far and the major reason
for that is we almost always detect it
too late by the time we diagnose it it's
often spread this is data from a nature
can see reviews paper a few years ago
shown in blue here are the percentages
of these four common cancers in the
United States they're diagnosed at stage
one and what you can clearly see his
lung lags well behind colorectal breast
and prostate with less than twenty
percent of patients being diagnosed at
the earliest stage as a result the
five-year survival for this disease
which is shown in purple is dismal less
than one in five patients will be alive
five years after I give them account
along cancer diagnosis and that number
hasn't really improved in the last three
decades so what the data is telling us
is that we in the clinical community are
not doing a very good job of detecting
this disease and its earliest and
potentially curable stage now when we
talked about early detection of lung
cancer we're actually talking about
identifying smokers we're at highest
risk for disease
since about ninety percent of lung
cancer in this country occurs in
individuals with a history of tobacco
smoke exposure this is a very
interesting graph this was taken from a
jammer paper published last year a study
looking at the prevalence rates of
smoking among adults across one in 100
countries in the world and the color
coding bar shows the darker red or
darker the color the higher the
prevalence rate of active smokers among
adults in that country so in the united
states were doing relatively well
smoking rates have come down
significantly as compared to a couple
decades ago roughly nineteen percent of
the adult population smokes every day
significantly lower than was the case to
three decades ago but if you go to other
parts of the world specifically out in
asia and india you see much higher rates
in fact sixty-five percent of males in
china actively smoke every day and so
the huge global burden on smoking but
the reality is not everybody who smokes
develops lung cancer so while ninety
percent of lung cancer occurs in smokers
only about ten to fifteen percent of
smokers may be as high as twenty will
develop lung cancer in their lifetime so
the real question for us is how do we
identify those smokers at highest risk
for disease and there was a huge
development three years ago published in
the new england journal of medicine that
has changed the landscape for early lung
cancer detection and that was the
National lung screening trial or the
so-called nlst and that was a study
where they took 50,000 high-risk smokers
and randomized them to the game annual
cat-scans of the chest as a screening
tool for lung cancer first as a control
group that got plain x-rays of the chest
and what they found this is a one
snippet of the data from that paper they
found that the group that got randomized
to CT scans of the chest had a twenty
percent reduction in their lung cancer
mortality on follow-up and arguing mad
CT screening can be a very effective way
to identify those individuals at highest
risk identify the disease earlier in
those people and potentially reduce
mortality from the disease
this is now effectively the standard of
care so based on that National lung
screening trial the US Preventive
Services Task Force came out with a
great B recommendation in support of CT
screening of high-risk smokers above a
certain age with a certain smoking of
history and now medicare has agreed to
reimburse for that so we're now in the
era of screening for lung cancer with
cat scans of the chest the problem is
they have two significant questions that
we need to address in this setting the
first is that cat can tend to pick up a
lot of abnormalities in the chest that
are not cancer in fact if you look at
the National lung screening trial data
from the New England Journal paper one
in four patients who got screen with a
chest CT had something abnormal
concerning for lung cancer only four
percent of that twenty-five percent
ended up having one cancer so we need
molecular biomarkers that can help us
distinguish a benign from malignant
lesion found on chess duty so diagnostic
biomarkers are desperately needed i'll
show you our attempt to do that today
are the second i'll need which i won't
have time to go into today but i'll talk
about at the very end briefly is a need
to identify a cruel among the population
of smokers and there are about 45
million current and close to 50 million
former smokers in this country who among
them should get screen annually with
jesse teeth we don't know what the most
effective way to use CT screening is and
if we had a molecular marker that could
identify folks at risk for developing
future disease we could then stratify
them into the CT screening surveillance
so this is a quick summary of 10 years
of work in our group trying to address
the two clinical needs on the previous
slide and we're doing that using gene
expression profiles measured in
bronchial airway epithelial cells
through the way we get those sounds is
to a procedure called bronchoscopy shown
on the slide where a fiber optic scope
is inserted via the nose or mouth down
through the trachea or down through the
vocal
into the so called trachea or windpipe
and we don't go very far in you go in
just after the trachea divides into a
right and left mainstem bronchus show
over here and then using a saito brush
through the working channel of that
scope we're able to rub up against the
inside of that airway wall at that site
and collect the relatively pure
population about the cereal cells this
is a key point we're not biopsy in the
airway but that brushing it and that
allows us to get a relatively clear
population of epithelium we can then
take those cells extract the RNA and run
gene expression profiling using a
microarray platform and so back in two
thousand four in 2005 we started our
studies on healthy volunteers a group of
active smokers and a group of never
smokers who agreed to undergo
bronchoscopy as volunteers we got their
airway epithelial cells and ran them on
a microarray and we found that active
exposure to tobacco smoke changes the
expression of hundreds and hundreds of
genes and and many micronase yourself no
major surprises there what was it
surprising was in 2007 when we went to
former smokers or people who read quit
smoking we found that most of the
changes that occur when you smoke revert
back to baseline within a few months of
quitting but it's upset about twenty
percent of the genomic alterations
persist years in fact decades after you
quit so essentially there is an
irreversible set of genomic damage in
these cells and that really set the
stage for the third bullet point on the
slide and the clinically relevant one
which is identifying a gene expression
signature in these cells that could
distinguish smokers who get lung cancer
from those who don't and i'll be showing
that's the biomarker moving into the
clinic now and i'll show you more about
that in the next couple of slides so i
end this slide by the fourth point at
the bottom left which is that we
recently published a paper together with
a group at md anderson showing that
these changes in the proximal early in
the bronchial airway which is not the
site where the tumor liza's those
genomic changes actually reflect genomic
changes with
in the tumor itself and mu Jason small
Airways i'll be showing you a little
more of that data in a moment but
important data to connect the field of
injury to the actual site of disease but
let me go back to the biomarker this is
a very busy slide but it's meant to
summarize what our biomarker is doing
clinically and so the question we're
trying to address is one of its year
that I alluded to earlier smokers up in
box one smokers undergoing bronchoscopy
for suspicion of cancer because it's
something abnormal seen on a CT scan or
x-ray of their chest the the reason we
do bronchoscopy is an initial test is
it's a non-invasive relatively
non-invasive outpatient procedure it's
safe and has a very low complication
rate but the problem is the broadcaster
bronchoscope itself can't go all the way
out to the periphery of the lung where
many of these abnormalities arise and
are seen on the cask n so we go out as
far as we can and then we try and brush
and biopsy and get cellular material
backs its diagnostic but we also failed
to make the diagnosis at the time of
bronchoscopy and the sensitivity of
bronchoscopy is anywhere from 30 to as
high as sixty or seventy percent for
diagnosing lung cancer so very often
will have a non diagnostic bronchoscopy
and then we have a clinical dilemma what
to do next which of these patients
should go for invasive biopsy to be
certain that this is not a cancer and
that's a biopsy that can be done with by
a needle through the chest wall or an
open surgical lung biopsy versus who can
we afford to watch non-invasively with
repeat imaging of the chest every three
to six months that's really the clinical
dilemma that we say week in and week out
enough pulmonary practices so what we
did in this study was very simple we
told the pulmonologist do all the
routine studies at the time of your
broadcast kabhi but before you pull the
scope out of that person's nose or mouth
stop in the right mainstem bronchus and
just spend an extra minute or two and
brush the normal-appearing mucosa at
that site we'll take those cells run
them on a microarray and the pattern
gene expression will tell us whether
that abnormality on the cat scan is a
benign lesion or a cancer so in the
event that the routine studies the
bronchoscopy this does and collects our
non-diagnostic you would use the gene
expression biomarker to decide this is a
patient who should go to surgery right
away or this is someone who doesn't
likely have cancer and therefore we can
avoid taking an unnecessary biopsy of
that Legion so if you go to box 5 under
5 it's a quick summary of the work we
published in 2007 where we identified an
80 gene expression signature in these
cells that could distinguish a benign
from malignant lesion on cat scan I had
relatively good sensitivity I just want
to highlight that in two relatively
small independent test sets it had a
very high sensitivity and high negative
predictive value when you combine the
gene expression biomarker with the
routine results collected at
bronchoscopy so it had 95% sensitivity
and ninety-five percent negative
predictive value which means you can
almost not quite but almost rule out the
presence of lung cancer which is what a
clinician needs in this setting I they
need to know who can they avoid sending
for an unnecessary invasive procedure so
this is a marker or biomarker that's
moving into the clinic and that's thanks
to two very large clinical trials that
have validated the biomarker I called
Aegis Warner he just to on this slide I
involved 28 medical centers in Canada
the United States and Europe mostly in
the US as you can see from this map more
than a thousand subjects were enrolled
at 25 centers all these subjects are
current or former smokers who are
undergoing bronchoscopy for suspicion of
having lung cancer they had all the
usual studies as per their standard of
care and then prior to the physician
ending the procedure they took an
additional brushing from the mainstem
bronchus the normal-looking name stem
bronchus and that those cells were sent
to a lab in North Carolina that ran it
on a microwave and measured the
expression of the biomarker
we then had to follow these people up
after the bronchoscopy for up to a year
until a final diagnosis was made for
that abnormality on their cat scan and
then we got to see is our biomarker
correctly predicting cancer status or
not so of the thousand patients the
first 600 were in so-called aegis-1 or a
CLIA trial those results have been
presented publicly in the last 12 months
and I'll share them with you today on
the next slide the you just to study
those data will be presented next week
at the American Thoracic Society meeting
for the first time but based on me the
correct or validation in both trials
various right has launched their tests
the tests that smell on the slide but
it's called / septa PRC eppa this is a
gene expression based assay for
improving the preoperative diagnosis of
lung cancer and reducing unnecessary
invasive procedures so here's the data
on the next slide that's been presented
at the American Thoracic Society meeting
last year's is the first trial that you
just one study what I'm showing you here
is an ROC curve where we're comparing
sensitivity versus specificity for our
gene expression biomarker across the
subjects in that first validation study
in in dashed lines over here are all
subjects in that trial and the solid
line next to it is though that subset of
individuals whose bronchoscopy was
non-diagnostic and that's important
because that's the intended use
population for the test we want to
obviously the bronchoscopy makes the
diagnosis you don't need the genomic
final marker so we're really focusing
our test on that subset of patients
whose bronchoscopy non-diagnostic and
the point is they have lovely the same
area under the curve of point seven
eight i'm the operating point on the
curve which doesn't project particularly
well let me try and use the whiteboard
here is somewhere over here the
correspondence or sensitivity that's
close to ninety percent and a
specificity of about fifty percent but
the most important parameter is the
negative predictive value or NPV on that
is greater than ninety percent so
if you have a non diagnostic philosophy
and a negative gene expression text
there's more than a ninety percent
chance you don't have lung cancer and
that's what we believe will drive
clinical utility of the test it allows
physicians to avoid unnecessary invasive
procedures and those patients who don't
have lung cancer and so again this was
an important validation now the test is
moving into the clinic as I mentioned
but one of the things that we absolutely
wanted to evaluate was whether those
changes were seeing in the main airway
next to the windpipe the genomic changes
reflect those that are found deep within
the tumor itself deep in the lung and so
this is a slide summarizing a manuscript
that was recently published in jnc I by
humam Coderre and Ignacio stupid MD
Anderson that I really have to
illustrate that point and what they did
at MD Anderson if they took 20
individuals who had non-small cell lung
cancer early stage disease who are
having their tumor taken out or
surgically resected they took out the
tumor and profile gene expression in the
tumor itself but they also found small
airways adjacent to the tumor leading
into the tumor that they were able to
brush and collect the epithelial cells
from and they ran those two on a
microarray and they compared their data
to our previous data sets in 2007 that
we had published looking at the the main
airway not the smaller waist with a
large airway near the windpipe and what
they found is shown on the next slide
which is I think very important they
found a group of genes that were
changing both in their tumor and
adjacent small airwaves so again if i
use my flow over here in dark green and
light green are the two groups of
samples that are behaving similarly for
gene expression is compared to normal
lung which is over here and gray and
there's a half about half of those jeans
are upregulated in the tumor and
adjacent normal airway over here and
about half the genes are being down
regulated a little more than half start
when three quarters i would say are
being down regulated and if you look at
those same genes in our prior data set
from the Nature Medicine publication
that's shown over here you can see that
those genes do a pretty good job of
distinguishing the airway of smokers who
have lung cancer which is in green from
those that don't have lung cancer which
are in white suggesting that at least a
component of the gene expression changes
in the proximal large early reflect
what's going on more distally in the
lung either in the tumor or in the
airways right next to the tumor so
really connecting the compartments
across this field of injury let me now
pivot from lung cancer to copd so as I
said lung cancer has been a bench to
bedside story COPD is a more recent
extension of the field of injury concept
and those are you're not familiar COPD
this is another smoking-related lung
disease again about ten to twenty
percent smokers develop it unlike in
lung cancer the issue is less about
early detection this is a chronic
debilitating disease for which we have
no good therapies nothing to reverse the
disease course and so we were looking at
airlie gene expression as a way of
measuring disease activity and response
to drug therapy and so we initially
started our work back in 2013 here where
we extended that same field of injury
concept to copd and we did that by
collaborating with Steven Lam at the
University of British Columbia Stephen
had a group of smokers who are being
screened for lung cancer through
bronchoscopy and they had ears about 900
Kerner former smokers with him without
COPD who've undergone that procedure
well we've been able to get brushings
from their bronchial airway run on a
microarray and then look to see whether
we can find the gene expression
signature that distinguishes smokers but
how does GOP from those that don't in
our initial analysis that we published
back in 2013 we took eighty seven
subjects who had COPD and match them 12
to two subjects that did not have COPD
but it's similar smoking history and
similar demographic features to the next
slide is the bottom line from that study
and that was published in 2013 we
identified a 98 gene signature that
could distinguish airway sample
from smokers who have COPD or an orange
here as compared to smokers without COPD
or in blue and I maybe should have
mentioned earlier but for those who are
not familiar with these heat maps each
of the columns of the patient again
orange of the COPD patient blue is a
patient without COPD and each of the
rows is a gene and a blue refers to
down-regulation of a gene expression in
the sample and red is a higher level
activity of that Thun of the sample and
you clearly see about half the genes are
down in patients with COPD and a little
more than half her up but what are you
interesting things about the genes that
are up is we're able to find a
transcription factor binding sites
enriched in the promoter region of those
jeans and that transcription factor is
called atf4 and why that's important is
atf4 is a very key mediator of the
unfolded protein response so in cells
are undergoing ER stress they elicit an
unfolded protein response and other
groups have previously shown that that
plays an important role in the
development and fizzy m'a at least in
animal models and when our data is
suggesting is that atf war may be
driving the teen expression changes
we've seen in the large airway of COPD
patients so to test that hypothesis what
we did is we took a bronchial epithelial
cell lines and culture and the cell
lines we took a call down here called
these two b cells and we overexpressed
atf4 and then did gene expression
profiling 24 hours after the
overexpression what we found is when you
look up here at the genes that are
changing in patients when who are
increased in expression in their airway
when they have COPD and that's shown in
be blue our patients without COPD or
injure patients with COPD this is a
group of genes that are upregulated with
disease those same genes are upregulated
in cell lines where you overexpress this
transcription factor aren't hearing that
this transcription factors in fact
driving some of the gene expression
changes that we're seeing in the airway
with disease if you had a really
important point
this is a really important point that we
want to make is if this in fact these
changes in the airway can tell us
something about disease activity and
disease pathogenesis perhaps we can use
them then to understand better who
responds to what you are in this disease
and maybe an intermediate marker of
therapeutic efficacy so our first stab
that that was connecting with a study
called flu cold shown on this slide this
was a large randomized relatively large
randomized clinical trial in capd with
110 smokers which disease will either
receive an inhaled steroid called
fluticasone that steroid plus a
long-acting bronchodilator called fell
mineral or placebo and then were
followed for 30 months and one of the
interesting parts of that study is that
the group in the Netherlands lander
study actually collected bronchial
samples from their airway for gene
expression studies pretreatment and then
again at six and 13 months after
treatment and what we found is on the
next slide when we ran those samples on
a microarray we found that our 98 gene
signature of COPD that I showed you
earlier tends to revert back towards
base line in the group of folks who are
in the treatment arms either the steroid
arm alone or the steroid plus
bronchodilator arguing that what we have
here is the dynamic field that may in
fact reflect response to therapy and
that that's an exciting observation
these are three box plots showing you
three of the 98 genes the expression of
those jeans is on the y axis on the x
axis of the groups so to the far left
for each box plot a little arrow there
are the brushings collected from the
smokers in in Vancouver with and without
COPD and so this first gene dual
specific phosphatase five is increasing
expression at baseline in the airway of
COPD patients if you then go to the
group old study which is to the right
you can see in the two treatment arms
the foot took a sonar more the focus on
plus I'll meador alarm that gene goes
back to baseline in terms of its
expression by 30 months whereas it
doesn't change in the placebo arm
and the same is true of the next two
genes on the slide so arguing that these
genes in fact are reversible these
alterations are reversible in the field
with treatment and that led then into
our next paper in 2014 where we showed
that the degree to which these genes
change in response to inhaled
corticosteroids in the airway represents
or reflects how well the patient does in
terms of improvement in lung function
with treatment so what we found in that
study again this is the glucose study we
found that those individuals that have a
stronger change in gene expression in
response to the drug they tend to have
better improvement in their lung
function a measure called fev1 and
that's over here as compared to groups
who do not change their gene expression
in response to steroids as much and the
other really important play wasn't just
one function but in panel c over here
its quality of life these are
questionnaires that we administer about
breathlessness and the group that had a
more robust response in terms of gene
expression in red had a dramatic
improvement in their quality of life in
terms of their their breathing and so
again arguing that gene expression in
the airway may not may be able to tell
us in COPD who is going to be more
likely to respond to inhaled
corticosteroids and and that's a lesson
area that we definitely have an unmet
clinical need because the last thing
i'll talk about in COPD is a recent
paper published last month in the
american journal vessel in critical care
medicine where we went on one step
further with this paradigm we believe
that COPD is not a single disease we put
a lot of patients in that under that
umbrella but the reality is we believe
is probably many different molecular
subclasses of that disease and
essentially certain subgroups are going
to respond better to certain drugs and
together with Stephanie Christiansen and
Prescott Woodruff at UCSF we did a study
where we looked at our gene expression
changes in the earliest field could be
patients and found similarities to a
study they had done in asthmatics and
why that's interesting is on the next
line cause we know and they have done a
fantastic job in the past the group at
UCSF of show
the subset of asthmatics have a th2
immune response active in their airway a
particular type of immune response that
is can be treated with drugs that target
that pathway and what we're doing here
is looking at the three genes in that
pathway certain b to c 0 c a1 and
periodic and looking at their expression
across the airway of smokers with COPD
and we find a small subset probably in
the range of ten percent although it's
not entirely clear a small subset of
those COPD patients have that costly
activated and and suggesting that they
also have a th2 immune response and it
may be responsive to drugs that target
that pathway if we then go into the
glucose study we similarly find a subset
that has that pathway active in the
airway epithelium and that substrate
tend to have a stronger response
clinically to in health corticosteroids
said ears you may have uncovered a
molecular subclass of COPD that might do
better with certain treatments and I
really believe that is the future of
personalizing treatment for that disease
I'm going to end so the last 10 min
appear on moving away from disease and
moving the airway field of injury
paradigm to understand response to
exposure in the environment and in one
of the things that driving this is that
we recognize that while our blog Phil
gene expression signatures both for lung
cancer and COPD appeared effective they
require a procedure to get the cells and
that's ok in certain clinical settings
such as the lung cancer diagnostic one
where you're doing the procedure anyway
but if we really want to move this to
larger population scale studies we need
to move out of the bronchial early to a
less invasive site and we've been
working ourselves we can get from the
buckle via coded as shown here as well
as the nasal epithelium it turns out the
nasal epithelium is the more promising
site anyway right now we're still
working in the mouth but let me let me
show you some of the data from the nose
that is promising just to be clear when
we say we're brushing the nose we're
brushing your fear of turbulent of the
nose that's shown over here so if you
you press on your nostril and look up in
the mirror and I guess you can do that
since no one's watching
you'll see a triangular protuberance on
the lateral wall of the nose we try to
highlight here a little better that
triangular protuberance is the inferior
turbinate it's about maybe a half a
centimeter in from your nostrils so what
we do is just put a little fighter brush
shown at the bottom of the slide and and
rub up against the bottom of that
terminate spend in two or three seconds
and get an incredible amount of
high-quality RNA we don't actually have
to use any type of local anesthesia for
doing this it is it is not invasive and
we've done this now on hundreds of
adults and hundreds of kids so with that
approach we then get a very good amount
of RNA from the epithelial cells of the
nose and we can run it on a micro rein
in our first studies back in 2010 with
this approach we showed if you take
healthy smokers that's and we
bronchoscopy them and collect their nose
and their bronchial airway on the same
visit and run them in parallel on a
microarray that the gene expression
changes in those two compartments mirror
each other in other words genes the
change in your bronchial early when you
smoke change it almost identical way in
your nose and so it's a very effective
surrogate so we're now that's of course
healthy smokers we're now moving into
smokers with and without lung cancer and
seeing whether the nose can be a
surrogate for the bronchial signature
that I showed you earlier that would be
exciting because then there'd be two
potential clinical applications the two
clinical needs I outlined at the
beginning one would be to after someone
has a chest CT shown over here and has
something abnormal found if you're not
going to get a bronchoscopy if the
lesion is too small to peripheral or the
patient is to affect it potentially
could basically brush the nasal
epithelium and let the gene expression
is a diagnostic marker but I actually
think the more exciting opportunity
resides upstream of chest CT over here
as a screening tool where we can use
this potentially on a population scale
to identify which smokers are highest
risk and therefore more likely to
benefit from undergoing CT screening
surveillance again these are early days
these are ideas and we
we have no published data to support
this but are trying to develop nasal
gene expression biomarkers for these two
specific clinical applications and one
of the ways we're doing that is through
an initiative called be camp this is a
very large Department of Defense grant
that we got three years ago four years
ago now that's allowing us to collect
airway epithelial cells years before
folks develop lung cancer and see
whether in fact we can use gene
expression in those sites to predict
future risk of disease which is what we
would need if we want to demonstrate
that we have a screening tool this is a
partnership between our group at Boston
University and a group at the american
college of radiology imaging network
called akron akron is the group that ran
over here the National lung screening
trial they're partnering with us and a
number of critical molecular bio marker
groups across the United States putting
UCLA Brown Vanderbilt MD Anderson to
develop molecular biomarkers to help
identify lung cancer early in military
personnel and veterans who have very
high risk of developing disease we have
11 or 12 clinical sites that are
collecting are recruiting patients and
collecting samples for active military
hospital Shin at the bottom 70 VA
hospital literally coast to coast and
what academic medical center and there
are a few critical files that are
actively enrolling patients right now
the first the top is a indeterminate
nodule study where we're taking 500
patients above a certain age with a
certain smoking history how the
indeterminate nodule generally speaking
between a half a centimeter I should
between six millimeters to the more
correct and 30 millimeters in size or
three centimeters in size this line is
incorrect there those patients are
followed for up to two years until final
diagnosis is made and collect a variety
of biospecimens including airway cells
that allow us to look whether our
biomarker and other biomarkers can
accurately diagnose cancer the second
project at the bottom i think is
potentially the more ambitious one which
is looking at healthy or folks that
don't have a nodule but our above a
certain age of a certain smoking history
and either have COPD or a first
relative of lung cancer and they're
being screened for lung cancer and
followed for up to four years for
development of disease and we're
collecting all types of biospecimens at
baseline and then annually along with
them getting screening chassis teased
every year and so the idea here is to
try and identify individuals who are
risk to develop future lung cancer using
a molecular bio marker in a number of
different biospecimens so again that is
how we're trying to move the nose and
other less invasive sites into the
screening setting last thing I'll say in
Milan five minutes is the beyond run
cancer the ability that of the upper
airway in the nose and specific to
measure response to exposure might allow
us to develop other biomarkers that are
important for public health and well I
don't have time to show you today we
recently developed a nasal gene
expression biomarker that can measure
secondhand smoke exposure and children
which is a significant public health
problem and we don't have very good
biomarkers for measuring exposure and
kids to secondhand smoke and we find the
gene expression those are very sensitive
tool for identifying which kids are
being exposed what I do want to talk
about is the second bullet point which
is using the nose to evaluate
alternative tobacco products and
especially of electronic cigarettes
which is a growing issue in this country
last bullet point which I won't talk
about today is this is actually
occurring in the mouth looking at gene
expression as they measure indoor air
pollution specifically smoking coal in
one of the provinces in China that has
among the highest rates of lung cancer
in the world it's mostly not in women
who don't smoke but instead are exposed
to indoor air pollution 24-7 due to
burning burning coal and more keating
their house and cooking and being
exposed to the fumes 24-7 and so we're
excited to try and expand the field of
injury concept to measure response to a
variety of exposures let me just show
you the second bullet point which is
looking at alternative tobacco products
so one of the advantages of being less
invasive than our sampling is we can now
follow someone over
time we can sample someone's nose your
mouth and repeatedly sample them as they
changed behavior so this is one study
that is not yet published but I've been
done together with Steve hacked and
Dorothy had to copy we're at the
University of Minnesota well we've taken
a group of smokers who are in a smoking
cessation program and we collect the
nasal epithelium a time point zero which
is pre quitting up here and then we
collect them at 4 8 16 and 24 weeks
after they quit running on a microarray
and we find the set of genes there's 101
genes in this heat map that change
relatively rapidly within the first six
months of putting we're highlighting in
the box over here a subgroup of these
genes that change extremely rapidly
change between the zero time points in
four weeks to change within first month
majority of these hundred genes are
changing within four to eight weeks of
quitting now why is that valuable so it
teaches us a little bit about some
biology and the kinetics of gene
expression in response to quitting but I
think the more exciting idea is it
provides us with a baseline that would
allow us to evaluate folks who don't
quit but rather switched to an
alternative tobacco product and try to
decide whether that switch whether that
product is in fact safer and causing
less alterations to the genome and so
this is the paradigm we're trying to now
use for electronic cigarettes and that
data is not yet published and I don't
have time to show it to you today but
what we're doing they're essentially of
having individuals who smoke regular
tobacco switch to electronic cigarettes
which may in fact be a safer alternative
but what we're doing is profiling their
airway gene expression pre and at time
points after switching to see whether it
looks similar to you individuals who
have quit smoking or not and hopefully
we'll have that data to publish very
soon so let me end there and to
summarize what hopefully I've shown you
today first and foremost that airway
gene expression specifically brought goe
gene expression can serve as a measure
of the physiological response to figure
out
smoking and potentially risk for
developing lung cancer we've
demonstrated that it can serve as a
diagnostic biomarker for lung cancer
detection and that is now moving into
the clinic as a commercial assay but we
also excited to move the same field of
injury paradigm to another
smoking-related long disease copd we're
there we think it can serve as a
therapeutic biomarker there are two
examples I should do that today one is
where gene expression in the airway felt
can tell you whether someone's
responding to an health corticosteroids
properly or not and the second idea is
that may help you identify or us
identify novel molecular subclasses of
the disease so called NGO types that
would allow us to personalize treatment
for the disease and that was a th2
example we recently published last but
not least on the slide is the idea that
this field of injury might extend to the
nose and that site could be used as a
less invasive surrogate tissue and that
will allow us to do a variety of
additional things including evaluate
folks who are switching to alternative
tobacco products and other inhales
exposures in the environment I'll end
there and just acknowledge a large list
of individuals in this final slide both
at BU and I try to be you that have been
responsible for the studies I showed
today as well as the funding agencies at
the bottom of the slide so I thank you
for attention I'm happy to take
questions I guess either I guess online
as this is done so thank you again
and in baba sai maybe hand it over to
you now
Bob lady there yeah thank you dr. skewer
for that informative presentation before
we get started on the question and
answer session I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit questions due to
submit questions by piping and then the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can our first question is from
Constantine and korjev I hope I
pronounced that correctly at the
Universidad autónoma de Madrid in Spain
there's a risk due to radon exposure by
the stones they are at the team ukhimath
epidemic excuse me epidemic illogical
data confirming this hypothesis is it
possible to detect earlier lung cancer
due to the radiation yeah that's a
that's an interesting question and I
think it reflects whether or not the
field of injury concept that I outlined
today is limited to tobacco smoke which
is in general the cause of lung cancer
more than ninety percent lung cancers
country or whether it could extend to
other causes of lung cancer you're
absolutely correct the radon exposure in
various parts of the world has been
associated with increased risk of lung
cancer through epidemiological studies
what's not clear is whether there would
be a field of molecular injuries
throughout the airway epithelium so
that's a question that we don't have an
attitude because we haven't studied it
specifically what I can tell you is
we're beginning to look at other
exposures other than tobacco smoke that
lead to lung cancer and seeing whether
they have the same field of injuries so
for example the study I mentioned in
China of non-smoking women who get one
cancer who have indoor air pollution
exposure where we are beginning to look
at whether there's a field of injury
there whether that can predict lung
cancer development those women that's a
very defined inhaled environmental
exposure of biomass combustion or indoor
air pollution we don't yet know for
other
like asbestos radon is a variety of
other environmental exposures associated
lung cancer and our challenge quite
frankly is getting access to airway
epithelial cells for patients who have
those exposures and so if there are
those out there that can access patients
with those exposures that's a very ripe
area for collaboration with our group
and we'd be absolutely interested in
studying them ok M are there any further
questions if there are please resubmit
them now well I'd like to take this time
to thank you again dr. spira and thank
you all in the audience for attending as
a reminder I'd like to let you know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for six months from
this live webcast you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you in
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thanks
again we'll see you next time goodbye